bonjour la halle aux jeunes de musique
pourquoi deux manches musique est au
point mort depuis deux ans ils ont
essayé lancer des projets artistiquement
très ambitieux ça c'est de la merde car
si dans moins de six mois monsieur
musique n'a pas rempli le lapi avec un
nouvel artiste
il cédera sa place de directeur mais
pourquoi on ne fait pas ça un prêtre un
rabbin et un email
réunis sur scène pour chanter ensemble
non mais je rigole pas là pour exister
quelque chose qui voulait à la
communauté juive mois ses habits jacob
j'ai dormi comme un bébé comme avec moi
je vous rappeler que nous sommes dans un
pays de culture chrétienne judéo
chrétien alors chrétienne
les rois de france n'étaient pas suisses
c'est dommage parce que vaut mieux avoir
l'avis de couper plutôt que la tête
basse et mal sa passe à mulhouse est sur
scène dont cinq minutes sociaux dans
l'équipe et j'ai fait les plus beaux
gland nous toutes les hauts-de-seine je
sais pas d'épater
si un fils est sain je suis pas celle
écouter in arabe
[Applaudissements]
tu peux me dire à quoi ça sert d'être
des vedettes on doit rester bloqué à
l'hôtel comme des cons et insectes la
sale [ __ ]
soit parce qu'un homme d'église et c'est
avec ce boys band que vous comptez
combler nos actionnaires tu sais jésus a
dit un jour je m'en fous ce qu'il a dit
c'est terminé salam shalom
alors moi nous sert voir c'est ça casse
toi donc la pression pour la gagner leur
vie en rose
et qui c'est qui va leur mettre ses
tontons stable
[Musique]